maddie i have to you i have to do this
please let mommy do this
no let me
you gotta let me do this
i'm done i'm off
so my current entrance uh didn't work
out but in front of me you guys may
notice that i have the new halo xbox
this is the infinite edition i'm so
excited about this and unfortunately i
missed the pre-order window and then was
not able to get one because they were
all sold out so i bought this from
someone in a parking lot
so the halo infinite edition xboxes were
all sold out and i found one online so
i'm going to meet this dude in this
parking lot it's still daylight
thankfully but he wanted to meet in the
back should we do this room yeah okay
just keep filming but don't let him okay
don't let him know that we're filming
because in case something happens all
right
[Laughter]
nothing else to see here nothing else to
see yep move along do you need help with
that yeah we're good
no nothing nothing else to see here
nothing else to see is he okay
nothing else is in there okay um there
you go yeah there you are oh my god
thank you so much thank you all right i
gotta go i gotta go yeah see ya
and now we're gonna unbox it i'm
currently home visiting my family and
jenna's here behind the camera and my
sister's husband also has an xbox here
so we're all gonna have a halo land
party and i am so excited let's unbox i
also wouldn't recommend that you buy
things from strangers in parking lots
because that could be potentially
dangerous as i am a trained professional
so don't do as i have done
like i can't freaking get this off
here we go
20 years
that's so wild like i remember playing
halo for the first time in college and i
was like what are you guys playing
let me play
oh my gosh i really need a knife this is
it's not working out
okay we're gonna need some scissors you
gotta save the box i know
maddie
honey you didn't let me have my warthog
entrance
no you're blocking the shield
you want to see what's in here buddy oh
holy moly look
at this this is this is this is an outer
cover this isn't even the actual thing
yet did you see dog's legs
oh it's a controller check this out dude
look at this look at this
you're going to see this in mommy's paws
for a long time you'll see smell here
learn about it learn about it 20 years
halo maddie
okay we've got our cables
anything else in there like maybe like a
surprise candy bar
i was really hoping for a surprise candy
bar honestly that should be like the new
norm okay here we go here we go here we
go here we go now look at this
i even like the outer little paper has
like little
stars on there oh oh
oh
baby coming
[Music]
oh look at this wow look at the inside
it's all blue
dude this looks so nice
wow
sorry i told her she'd play on her two
minutes before bath time well
two minutes
nakey baby
brittany have you ever do you know have
you ever heard of halo the video game
that daddy plays
does daddy play video games here bryn
what is this
broken
broken even though there's no batteries
in it okay
look at that
yeah okay check that out like this thing
looks incredible
man we are gonna have a time
this holiday season
[Music]
i like that this is all like etched in
too
that's really nice
i love that this inside is blue like
obviously if you've seen this before the
inside is green
the child
is
[Music]
taking everything off the desk
celebrating 20 years oh man i'm very
excited about this so i guess basically
it's now unboxed this video
has
gotten a little silly
i know
i mean honestly like my favorite thing
is the inside here because you can see
that normally where this is all green
it's all
now like a blue coated color and the fan
can you see the fan inside
like that's also like a black and blue
speckled color
this is a this is nice this is actually
really nice
are you able to see that yeah nice
does it make a special sound i bet it
does
i bet it makes a special sound
[Music]
i'm hoping we get a special sound
he didn't press the right button
what a loser
you did
no i didn't i was the freaking
disc eject what are you idiot okay
that was pretty special
the fan air
smells
so good
[Music]
wow
it's really great
it's
like it smells like 20 years of halo
you want to smell no okay
the offer is still there if you want
let's plug in this controller plug it in
i mean let's put those batteries in
it look at that oh yeah that's beautiful
if you guys need me i'm just gonna be
here smelling the fan air out of the
xbox this is what dogs do jesse
i'm jesse sniffin hello
hi i'm cortana a little touching wi-fi
here a little touch of wi-fi there
we got the tv being set up in the back
brian's on on duty
can't confirm or deny we may be playing
we may not be oh should i plug it back
in okay wait wait i want you to see the
fan well i can't just i just see like
the the blue oh yeah on top i don't see
the fans it looks incredible
this is like whoa wow it's beautiful now
you see it oh no you don't like i
totally think that this was definitely
worth meeting a stranger and taking this
from the back of his car yeah
right i had to give him cash but like
you should have checked to make sure it
was in there first
you're right
i just gave him money he looked
trustworthy
all right well don't use my judgment um
i'm gonna go hook this up and play halo
so let me know if you guys ended up
getting one of these or if you're
playing halo this weekend let me know
maybe you'll see me in the lobby and if
you do
please be nice to me be nice to me
but think about fashion look at this
fashion
[Music]
[Applause]